-You and Cory Booker -- I know
you have tried to
spearhead police reform.
This is something that
has stalled in the Senate.
Do you have any optimism
moving forward
that there is
going to be something
that can get through the Senat
and make it to
the president's desk?
-I'm hopeful, but, you know,
everyone has to participate.
So, the work that
Cory Booker and I did
was around the
Justice in Policing Act,
and most of our colleagues o
the Democratic side
in the Senate support it.
On the House side,
there was bipartisan support
for a similar measure,
which has now been named
the George Floyd
Justice in Policing Act.
And bipartisan support.
The Congressional Black Caucus
was the leader on it.
And I am urging Mitch McConnell,
along with many of us,
put it now
on the floor for a vote,
because it's just -- It's fair
It's reasonable. It's practical.
It says that
we should have things like
a national standard for
excessive use of force.
So when a police officer
uses excessive force,
the question we should ask
is not "Was that reasonable?",
which is what,
currently, we ask.
We should -- Because you can
reason away anything.
We should be asking,
"Was that necessary?"
We're saying
that there should be
independent investigations
because the prosecutor
who works with that
police department every da
will at least have an appearance
of a conflict of interest,
and we want to bring
integrity to the system.
So, these are some of the things
that we're talking about,
and, you know, people are
marching in the streets
by the hundreds of thousands
if not millions.
People who seemingly have
nothing in common
are joining together
because they are now seeing,
in vivid detail, because o
smartphones, what communitie
and, in particular, the
black community,
has known for generations.
And there needs to be
accountability and consequence
on this issue,
and we don't need to study it.
We've studied it
for generations.
Emmett Till's mother was tryin
to help us figure this out
when she had the courage t
leave that open casket
to show the world the brutalit
that we're talking about.
We don't need to
study it anymore.
We need to act, and that's wha
our legislation would do.
And so I encourage everyone to
encourage Mitch McConnell
to put it on the floor
for a vote.
-He seems to be
a pretty easily convinced gu
when it comes to bringing
something to vote.
Old Mitch just needs
a little encouragement.
-Well, yeah,
we can encourage him to pu
the John Lewis Voting Rights Act
on the floor for a vote
so we can put teeth
back into voting rights
and make sure that the elections
that we have coming up
allow everyone to
participate equally.
-I want to finish with this.
There is a short list.
I don't know if
you are aware of this.
There is a short list for V.P.
and it's, like,
a list of names of people.
And some would say
that you might be on that list
So do you want to give me
a very safe answer
that you might have preplanned
that you give to people
when they say, "Would you
want to be vice president?
-[ Laughs ]
So, okay, let me read my answer.
-There you go.
We'll just leave it at that.
-No, but let me --
No, let me say this.
Let me say this.
I am honored to be
a part of this discussion.
And I say this to you from
the bottom of my heart and soul.
We have to elect Joe Biden
the next President of
the United States,
and I will do everything in my
power regardless of where I am
We have to elect him.
We cannot endure another
four years of Donald Trump
We need a president
who, at this moment in time,
has compassion, who was empathy,
who has a sense of dignity
self-dignity, and lifting up
the dignity of others,
somebody who fights
for working families.
That's who Joe Biden is.
I know Joe.
This is literally who he is.
And we need to save the soul
of our country.
We really do.
We need a president
who cares about
the people and loves the people.
But, you know,
talk about John Lewis.
Let's connect these two things
You know, part of the leadership
and the power of John Lewis was,
he was motivated by love.
-Well, I think that is
a nice place to leave it.
Thank you so much for
making time for us
again, Senator.
-Thank you, Seth.
Good to be with you again.
-Have a great rest of your week.
-Take care.